note to make matters slightly more
confusing javascript allows you to
assign to variables you've never even
declared before in this example I took
the VAR statement off of this assignment
operation so foil has not been declared
anywhere in our whole program when you
do this kind of assignment variables
that you're assigning to for the first
time will be added automatically to the
global scope and not to whatever scope
you did the assignment in this is
actually a pretty bad practice because
leaving the VAR keyword off is more
often done by accident than on purpose
even if you do purposefully decide you
want to do this it'll be very confusing
for other people reading your code and
they'll probably assume you've just made
a mistake
also note that unlike a lot of other
languages not all curly braces in
JavaScript are relevant for scoping
blocks on if statements or while
statements and other looping constructs
like that do not create new scopes only
the curly braces that you find on a
function statement creates a scoped
scoping limitations are actually very
useful they allow us to think about less
of our program all at once so we don't
want to subvert them by leaving off var
declarations so for now just remember to
declare every variable with a var
keyword in whichever lexical scope you
want that variable to live